un romance
este barrio era su reino
estos dos mafiosos son yakuzas durante
décadas han controlado la industria del
juego y las apuestas ilegales aquí
ganábamos más de nueve mil dólares al
día cada una de nuestras máquinas
tragaperras aportaba unos dos mil 900
dólares nos aseguramos de que ninguna
otra banda viniera a nuestra tierra
éramos muy poderosos muy violentos
este padrino es el jefe de un imperio en
decadencia al que sólo le quedan unos
cuarenta hombres la mitad de los cuales
están en prisión
esta es su oficina esta es una de las
peculiaridades de japonés las
organizaciones criminales no están
oficialmente prohibidas incluso tienen
locales y son oficialmente asociaciones
es el fundador de nuestro clan es
alguien que está en lo más profundo de
nuestros corazones y eso es muy
importante para nosotros pero estos
modelos tienen ahora dificultades para
atraer a nuevos reclutas se dice que el
número de yakuzas es diez veces menor
que hace medio siglo con una edad media
de más de 50 años gangsters canosos
él también era un yakuza usted se está
yendo toda la vieja generación
o saca la tercera ciudad del país fue
otro ahora uno de los bastiones del
hampa y en particular del llama gucci um
y es por mucho el grupo mafioso más
grande del archipiélago y casi uno de
cada dos ya cosas siguen en el poder hoy
en día este abogado defendió a su líder
el padrino de los padrinos
era el número uno cuando había una
azafata que le gustaba en un barrio
una del brazo y le decía cariño a
quien quieres que maté por ti
este hombre que tenía todo el poder en
japón terminó asesinado en los años 80
una guerra entre bandas crea el caos en
el país y provocar víctimas civiles
colaterales este es el principio del fin
de los yakuzas la policía tolerante
hasta ahora decide actuar contra este
gobierno en la sombra
y la yakuza había penetrado en el
mercado de valores en el sector
inmobiliario en la gestión de
aeropuertos e incluso en las centrales
nucleares
estos grupos violentos estaban por todas
partes en sectores clave de la economía
y los japoneses empezaron a decirse
ya no los queremos hacer a través de una
serie de leyes la policía ataca la
cartera de la mafia su tesorería
cualquier persona o empresa que colabore
o financia a la mafia se arriesga a ser
condenada a
los yakuzas perderán gradualmente sus
ingresos
pasaron del cielo al infierno
en 30 años el clan más rico se ha
convertido en una banda sin dinero y con
muchísima fe el propio abogado ha pagado
el precio de esta lucha despiadada su
tarjeta profesional fue finalmente
revocada el tesoro de la yakuza es la
industria del placer como aquí en
ikebukuro un barrio caliente de la
capital
como puedes ver aquí hay bares y
establecimientos que ofrecen servicios
sexuales por lo que es una fuente de
ingresos para la yakuza este policía
retirado luchó durante décadas contra
las extorsiones de la yakuza en el mundo
nocturno
anteriormente todos los establecimientos
tenían que pagar a la yakuza una tasa
denominada de protección que oscilaba
entre 170 y más de 900 dólares al mes
por bar así cuando un clan controlaba
100 bares podía ganar 80 mil euros al
mes incluso mucho más y eso es lo que
conseguimos controlar
pero el policía no canta victoria
me gustaría decir que las mafias son un
poco como las cucarachas son muy
resistentes
hoy en día hay clanes que son muy buenos
en informática especialmente los jóvenes
yakuzas
y en este momento su prioridad son las
estafas para conseguir ayudas económicas
vinculadas a kobe
es una placa
los yakuza se encuentran nuevas estafas
pero su vida cotidiana se ha convertido
en un infierno se les prohíbe tener una
cuenta bancaria un contrato de seguro
incluso arrendar un apartamento el
gobierno les ha quitado sus derechos más
básicos volviendo al plano saca estos
mafiosos aceptaron hablar con nosotros
porque ahora se presentan como víctimas
no sólo ellos sino también sus
familiares
como no se permiten tener una cuenta
bancaria no podemos hacer una
transferencia para pagar la cafetería de
nuestros hijos y así la escuela se da
cuenta inmediatamente de que somos ya
cosas esto genera discriminación racismo
contra nuestros hijos y nietos
los hijos de los mafiosos a veces son
rechazados en las escuelas por miedo a
ser tildados de delincuentes por la
noche la pandilla recorre la vida
nocturna de osaka en el pasado eran
temidos y respetados hoy nadie los
reconoce
[Música]
francamente tengo problemas para
sobrevivir pero qué más puedo hacer no
sé hacer nada más que ser un yakuza
es difícil sentir pena por los
delincuentes sin embargo la reinserción
de los yakuzas aunque despierte poco
interés en la población se ha convertido
en un problema para las autoridades
japonesas ofrecerles un futuro fuera de
la delincuencia es la única manera de
contemplar el fin de la mafia